I was born in the 50s raised in the 50s
and 60s in the Midwest I had a great and
wonderful upbringing by two great
wonderful parents out of college I went
to work for the military and spent
almost 30 years working for the
government
it was a great experience and I'm now
retired and looking to try new things I
try to take care of mind body and spirit
and I'm really proud that at my age I
still feel great and I'm hoping to
continue for many years in the future I
was always a little bit inclined to
think outside the box and come to my own
conclusions about life and what I wanted
and what I did one of which was I've
come to enjoy a clothing free lifestyle
back in the day they called us nudists
now they call us natureís but I just
call it natural and fun when I read the
article in GQ about dr. Allison
procedure it really started me to
thinking because a bigger penis heaven
in the back of my mind were some years
but I should emphasize that going into
the surgery I did so not because I felt
I was smaller and inadequate in any way
it was just something that I wanted to
do for myself I guess you could call it
an act of vanity and I guess that's okay
I think we're all entitled to do things
that make us feel better about ourselves
[Music]
after the surgery from a lengthwise
standpoint I think I gained about an
inch and a half so a year later soft I'm
approximately seven inches long in seven
and a half inches in girth and believe
me that size does draw attention as I
understand that the weight of the
implant will continue to stretch the
ligaments such that you can achieve
additional length increases over a
period of time however I have to say if
what I have now is what I end up with I
couldn't be happier now today I
participated in a clothing-optional yoga
I go to Burning Man advanced I'm a
member of a Mutis group and I
participated recently in the world make
bike ride and I had a lot of fun and I
have to admit one of the big reasons I
had a lot of fun was because a lot of
heads turned to look at me whether we
admit it or not we all enjoy being in
the spotlight and thanks to dr. Elice
the spotlight comes on when my hands
come down
[Music]